bien ahora trabajaremos en nuestro
primer circuito de amplificadores
operacionales así es como se verá el
circuito observa que el signo positivo
está arriba en este caso vamos a tener
una fuente de voltaje por aquí
el más y el menos del voltaje de entrada
esa es nuestra señal de entrada
en la salida tenemos el voltaje
salida
y está conectado de esta manera una
resistencia y otra resistencia a la
tierra
y esta vuelve a la entrada inversora
analicemos este circuito y veamos lo que
hace ahora sabemos que aquí se conecta
la fuente de poder a estos dos puntos el
símbolo de tierra significa cero votos y
queremos analizar este circuito que
sabemos de esto sabemos que el voltaje
de salida equivale a algo de ganancia
escribiré la ganancia justo aquí un
número muy muy grande por de más o menos
- así que tenemos esto de más es este
punto de aquí y de menos es este punto
de aquí y también sabemos que la
corriente llamémosla y más y menos es
igual a cero y esa es la corriente que
pasa por aquí ésta es y menos y esta es
y más
y sabemos que ambas son 0 ahora lo que
quiero hacer es describir lo que está
sucediendo adentro de este símbolo
triangular con más detalle construyendo
un circuito ideal y el circuito ideal
para un amplificador se ve de esta
manera
de menos aquí y el de más aquí
este es el voltaje diferencial
y de este lado tenemos un nuevo símbolo
que no has visto antes usualmente
dibujado con una forma de diamante y
esta es una fuente de voltaje pero es un
tipo especial de fuente de voltaje se
llama
fuente
el voltaje
controlada
x
paul
es igual que una fuente de voltaje
excepto por una cosa excepto que la ve
en este caso el voltaje de salida
es igual a la ganancia por temas menos
de menos así que el voltaje es
controlado por el voltaje en otro lugar
y eso es lo que significa que sea
controlada por voltaje bien acabamos de
obtener nuestra expresión de ganancia
aquí y hemos dibujado un diagrama que
representa nuestra expresión de voltaje
para nuestro circuito ahora
específicamente aquí hemos dibujado un
circuito abierto de demás
y ve - así que sabemos que esas
corrientes son 0 este modelo
este bosquejo del circuito representa
las dos propiedades de nuestro
amplificador operacional tomaré un
segundo aquí y dibujar el resto de
nuestro circuito alrededor de este
modelo pero necesito un poco más de
espacio
incluyamos el resto de nuestro circuito
aquí tenemos nuestra fuente de voltaje
conectada a b más y este es el voltaje
de entrada y por aquí tenemos al voltaje
de salida
veamos cristal está conectado a dos
resistencias
y la parte de abajo está conectada a la
tierra
y esto estaba conectado
nuestra meta ahora es encontrar el
voltaje de salida
en función
el voltaje de entrada
eso es lo que buscamos veamos si podemos
hacer eso démosle a nuestras
resistencias nombres llamemos a estas
r2 nuestros nombres favoritos de siempre
y ahora que todo está etiquetado a este
punto de aquí podemos llamarlo ve -
nuestros nudos son de menos el voltaje a
la salida y el voltaje a la entrada
tenemos a de sal llave menos veamos si
podemos encontrarlos lo que haría es
empezar a escribir algunas expresiones
denunciados que se son verdaderos por
ejemplo se que el voltaje de salida
equivale a a
por qué
más menos
- eso es lo que este amplificador nos
dice que es verdad ahora que otra cosa
hace veamos esta cadena de resistencias
aquí esta cadena de resistencias de
hecho se parece mucho a un divisor de
voltaje y de hecho es un muy buen
divisor de voltaje recuerda que dijimos
que esta corriente de aquí de cuánto es
esta corriente de aquí es de 0 puedo
utilizar la expresión de divisor de
voltaje que se en este caso sé que ve -
esta es la ecuación de divisor de
voltaje es igual a
x que por la resistencia de abajo
recuerdas esto r 2 sobre r 1 más r 2 así
que la expresión de divisor de voltaje
dice que cuando tienes un conjunto de
resistencia es así con un voltaje arriba
y la tierra abajo esta es la expresión
para el voltaje en el punto medio lo que
haré ahora es tomar esta expresión y la
sustituye de ahí hagamos eso
ya tenemos suficiente espacio escribamos
la aquí puedo decir que sí
es igual a a
por ve más
menos
el voltaje de salida
x
r2 sobre r1 y r2
vamos bien hasta ahí continuamos
trabajando en esto
de salida es igual a a
por qué
más o menos
x
r2 sobre r1 y r2 bien ahora llevaré
todos los términos del voltaje de salida
al lado izquierdo intentemos eso eso me
da fe
más
de sal
por r 2 sobre r uno más
r2 y eso es igual a
por qué
y más y de hecho puedo cambiar eso ahora
de más a que equivale de más es igual a
d
de entrada
bien sigamos ahora puedo factorizar el
voltaje de salida
el voltaje de salida por 1
más
por r 2 sobre
r1 y r2 y eso equivale a por el voltaje
de entrada
bien nos estamos acercando y nuestro
objetivo original es encontrar el
voltaje de salida en términos del
voltaje de entrada así que tomaré toda
esta expresión de aquí y la pasaré
dividiendo al otro lado para tener
únicamente al voltaje de salida en este
lado y al voltaje de entrada en el otro
lado hagamos más espacio
después de hacer eso puedo decir que el
voltaje de salida
es igual
por el voltaje de entrada
/ esta expresión grande uno más
por r 2 sobre
uno más
2 bien esa es la respuesta
esa es la respuesta
el voltaje de salida es igual a una
función del voltaje de entrada
ahora quiero hacer una observación muy
importante aquí esta será una
simplificación muy útil este es el punto
en el que nuestra teoría de
amplificadores operacionales se vuelve
muy sencilla
observa lo que pasa aquí sabemos que es
un número gigante y está en el orden de
diez a las cinco o diez a las seis y lo
que sea que tengamos aquí si nuestras
resistencias son de valores normales
sabemos que un número gigante por un
número normal aún será un número
bastante grande comparado con uno
este uno es casi insignificante en esta
expresión de aquí lo que haré es
cancelarlo confía en mí diré no no
necesito este más si este número de aquí
ya es un millón diez a las seis y esta
expresión es cercana a un medio entonces
este total es un medio de diez a las
seis o medio millón y eso es muy grande
comparado con uno así que es bastante
seguro ignorar al uno es muy muy pequeño
ahora cuando hago eso de lo que pasa
después tengo a tanto arriba como abajo
en la expresión y puedo cancelar
eso también así que la acb esto es
bastante asombroso tenemos este circuito
amplificador y de repente tengo una
expresión aquí donde la ganancia no
aparece la ganancia no aparece y esto en
que se convierte nos queda que el
voltaje de salida
es igual al voltaje de entrada x que x
r1 y r2 dividido entre r 2 así que
nuestro amplificador nuestro circuito de
retroalimentación resulta ser el voltaje
de salida igual al voltaje de entrada
multiplicado por una proporción de las
resistencias que agregamos al circuito
esta es una propiedad muy útil al
trabajar con amplificadores
operacionales en circuitos en
amplificadores con ganancias muy grandes
lo que hemos hecho es elegir la ganancia
de nuestro circuito basándonos en los
componentes que le agregamos a nuestro
amplificador no está determinado por la
ganancia del amplificador siempre y
cuando la ganancia del amplificador sea
muy muy grande y para amplificadores
operacionales es una muy buena
suposición es muy grande ahora esta
expresión surgió con un signo positivo
cierto todas las resistencias tienen
valores positivos así que esto se
refiere a un
li
cada tour
no
sol
solo para hacer un ejemplo rápido cierre
uno y r dos son iguales entonces
acabamos con una expresión que se ve de
esta manera el voltaje de salida es
igual a r1 r2 r3 sobre r es igual a 2
así que la ganancia es 2 por el voltaje
de entrada
solo para hacer un pequeño bosquejo para
recordar cómo se ve este es el
el voltaje de entrada que tenemos aquí
tenemos una resistencia
otra resistencia hacia la tierra
este es el voltaje de salida
esta es la configuración de un
amplificador no inversor armado con un
amplificador operacional estas dos
resistencias y este divisor de voltaje
conectado a la entrada negativa así es
como se ve el circuito amplificador no
inversor y este es uno de los patrones
familiares que verás una y otra vez a
leer diagramas o cuando diseñen sus
propios circuitos